[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's go to Stacy and Virginia Beach
Virginia what's going on
Stacy good afternoon good afternoon how
are
you um I'm okay um I have a issue I have
about um $30,000 in debt that I
just since Co I you know tried paying it
and I put it in a um with a
consolidation company and I've just
within the past couple of months it's
like impossible for me to get it down
any further and I've been paying for
this would be the fourth year um so I've
paid it off a huge amount of it but this
last 30,000 and I'm like
$3500 behind now and because of work
situation changing and everything what
kind of Deb is it I don't know what to
do it well
um a few years ago um two it's credit
card it's it's all credit card um um two
of our daughters were going through
really really bad times and I was making
good money and um had excellent credit
in the 800s and I gave them each a
credit card one of them two of them in
their name but still on my credit and
their situations you say in their name
but so it was it's in your name okay
their name so you just gave them a
credit card that was they're like an
authorized user but on your account
correct okay correct and
um unfortunately you know broken
promises and um it it just hasn't
happened so I ended up putting um once I
found out that they were not making
their payments um I tried to keep up
with it as best as I could but because
they had been late and stuff um it
snowballed and one of them even used it
for like rent cash
advances so did you take them off of
these
cards oh yeah okay great so there's no
more debt being accumulated but you're
on the hook and they're not paying
another
dime yes and I paid um alog together it
was um with now this is with the
interest and the fees and everything um
it got up to
135,000 oh my sheesh wait
wow yeah I paid everything but um this
last 30,000 you got it from 135 down to
down to 30 you have any other
debt no okay and what's your household
income well see see that's the thing my
husband does not know that I'm paying
this girl boy he doesn't know about the
debt he would disown them it would
totally fracture our family and um and
you don't think he's going to find out
one
day um no no because we we don't have
debt except for the
only uh so you have to use your own
income and do this secretly with your
own bank account because he can't out
because it would destroy the family let
me hold on a second can you flip the
script for a second and imagine the
tables were turned and your husband had
done what you did and took out these
credit cards and you know so on and so
forth well no he knew he knew they had
he knew that they had them he thought he
thinks that they're making their payment
either way either way if the tables were
turned and he knew what you know right
like just put yourself in his shoes
would you want to be told
um if it wouldn't be that I know he will
disown them and would you children
simple question would if it would you
want to know do you feel like you would
have the right to know if you as a
couple had incurred
$135,000 of debt do you have the right
to
know sure yes ma'am and here's the thing
if he disown them that's a decision he
made mhm so you can own your part you
did a lot of stupid stuff but it's up to
him he does with this situation yeah and
but that would mean me not getting to
see my grandchildren no it
wouldn't oh sure it would because both
of them would take it you know the
opposite they would take it as you
tattled on dad to us and now I'm not
gonna you're not our mom anymore and
you're not going to get to see the kids
as punishment exactly look if that's how
this whole thing's going to go down
there's not much of a relationship there
to begin with yeah how are you already
not resentful towards the daughters
um I'm pretty sad this relationship
can't be in great shape right now as it
stands well there circumstances that led
to it and there's no excuse that if they
could and I had put it in my email
they're not in a position they're
literally just getting by what they the
initial you know that they
did it's there's no excuse for it
because it shouldn't have been hidden
from me because then I could have done
something to help to rectify at that
time but they they're their own women
how old were they when when this were
taking place over
18 oh yes I think but they were both one
one was getting out of a she didn't know
um she was relocating for her job went
up there the whole family was supposed
to move up when kids got Summer and the
now ex-husband decided he was wasn't
moving and you know and the other was in
a horrible abusive marriage here's the
thing here's here's what I want to say
all those things are really difficult
those are difficult situations to manage
you're their mom you want to step in and
help you helped in the wrong way and now
everybody's reaping the results of that
and in this case the consequences of
that if you wanted to help you could
have given them a gift you could have
said hey I you know the the right way to
help in these situations is not to open
a line of credit
where they can spend and spend it's to
say you know what I'm going to cover
your rent this month or I'm you know and
you're you're taking the action yourself
and you've still got all the power in
the control um as far as the money and
they can't create debt on your behalf so
yeah I think that the hard part here is
you're having to come to GPS with like
this I tried to help and I botched it
and it's still like it's still reaping
bad fruit and that sucks and I think
also it's easy for you to say oh my
husband he'll disown them and he'll do
this and he'll do that and keep it from
him but you guys have all you've all got
to get in a room and be like this is
what's going on and it might be an
episode of Jerry Springer but you guys
can't keep all these secrets off to the
side and dad doesn't know this and Mom
if you tell them you're disloyal there's
no healthy boundaries here and there's
no healthy relationship taking place
here man I wish John deloney was here
because he would get up get up all into
this this is largely relational but the
thing is here you have you said work
issues do you have an income right
now yes
but due to covid and it's still where we
live it's still not 100% open back up
and to do where Virginia's not open
where what I do with my job and I can't
say or else then that just pinpoints me
okay um so my income has dropped
drastically what do you make today past
couple of years um geez probably only
like 30,000 right now you need to go
find a new
career well I've been trying I I
probably put in a dozen to two dozen if
you go work a retail job at $16 an hour
you just got a
raise well when what does your husband
make
um good money due to six figures career
his career and you guys have totally
separate
finances no we have joint also but this
was on my own okay well you're not going
to be able to pay off this $330,000 you
need his help right now unfortunately
and which means you're going to have to
go and say listen I'm sorry I committed
Financial infidelity I need your help
fixing this I want to salvage the
relationships I need your help this is
what marriage is deal with a hard stuff
together yeah she's going to have to
she's going to have to swallow her pride
and go in there and ask for help this is
her spouse and by the way combining
incomes doesn't mean that you have a
joint account that you both put some
into and then you have your separate
accounts off to the side that's not
combining finances that's playing
yourself and you're playing your
marriage too